things have changed you see something
you like DoubleTap you see something you
dislike tweet about it you're in a
relationship update your relationship
status on a browser news do it online
want to find out your credit score do it
online with a trusted agency wanna trade
stocks use an app interested in buying
some new clothes do some online shopping
wanna track your calories use an app
having health problems googling having
relationship problems google it thinking
of going outside take your phone with
you what could possibly go wrong the
deaths of this industry the the really
darkest corners have yet to be exposed
to any light whatsoever every location
that you visit physically can be
recorded this valuable data is now a
commodity that is traded amongst a
handful here's how it works your name
your age your height your weight where
you live where you work your family your
friends your likes your dislikes your
phone number your email your health
conditions your buying habits your
credit score your political beliefs your
religious beliefs who you texts these
are all examples of data points little
bits of information and those little
bits of information are very valuable
things why I hear you ask and valuable
to who well advertisers would be a good
start with a large amount of data an
advertiser would know exactly who they
should target and how they should target
in order to make you buy well thank
goodness they don't have access to your
data then right wrong they do have
access to your data and it's not your
data anymore
welcome to the world of data brokers a
two hundred billion dollar industry
based on selling your personal
information to other companies right now
you're probably imagining some tech
giants like Google or Facebook but
that's not who I'm talking about as far
as we know those companies don't sell
your data
no I'm talking about the others I'm
talking about more than 4,000 companies
in the US alone faceless companies
companies that you've probably never
heard of companies that are operating in
the shadows with very few rules
gathering all your personal data without
you knowing information about your
health your buying habits the
restaurants reach out the supermarket's
that you buy from then negotiating that
very data with other companies for a
hefty profit in the millions all behind
your back I don't know about you guys
but I want a piece of that pipe if we're
gonna start profiting off people's
information we're gonna have to start
collecting that data it sounds quite
difficult doesn't it but it's a lot
easier than you would think nowadays
people give out their information
willingly and without realizing that
this data can be extracted and sold
begin with public information things are
you can find on someone's social media
pages there is nothing to hack people
were gonna provide their own pictures
their own information the pages that
they liked the places that they visited
relationship statuses hobbies friends
lists look at property records and Land
Registry court records birth
certificates voter registration
information bankruptcy records all of
these things can be publicly accessed
Avastin or enough data now we're gonna
need more than that so go ahead and find
companies who are willing to sell their
customers data yep your favorite retail
store that offered you those loyalty
cards they've got all the information of
what you've been purchasing when you've
been purchasing it and how often you've
been purchasing and guess what it's all
up for sale retailers are finding out
that they have a secondary source of
income which is that the data about our
customers is probably just about as
valuable maybe
and more so than the actual product or
service that they're selling to the
individual go ahead and buy data from
vehicle licensing agencies the ones that
have your name address and other
personal information or selling drivers
personal information create free
websites apps and other services that
are designed to look ordinary behide
their actual intention what web visitors
don't realize is that take five is real
business is collecting and selling the
information put trackers on these
websites and apps that allow you to see
things like it uses location and their
contact list those cookies that you see
on websites they have a sweet name don't
they and you probably have no idea what
they do but a lot of these cookies are
tracking your online behavior the
websites you visited the news that
you've read the online purchases that
you've made this is an entire list of
vendors which a website is willing to
hand out your information to
but is it even legal you're asking of
course it is these people have agreed to
handing over their information
they're the ones who clicked accept and
agree on the website pop ups which
requested the use of their personal data
they're the ones who left their social
media pages public they're the ones who
like those Facebook pages or posted
about their thoughts and interests these
are new times were living in remember
and although these people don't know
what they've actually been signing up
for we've still got their digital
signature any information you get as
much information as you can get all of
these data points are little pieces of
gold and the more data that you collect
the better set you're going to be for
the next stage of this process easy data
isn't just random bits of information
what data is truly at its core is human
behavior and with the data that you've
gathered as a broker it's time to start
making your product all this data needs
to be sorted aggregated from all these
people that we've taken data from we
need to start creating profiles at the
heart of this industry
we don't care whether a person likes
this brand or that brand or whether they
prefer baseball or basketball whether
they shop at Walmart
Morrison's what we're looking for is
patterns and with all this data that
we've gathered we can start to identify
patterns and how you behave and what
your overall personality is like by
looking at just a few of your likes on
Facebook we can accurately predict what
your political affiliations are by
looking at just your purchase history we
can guess how old you are whether you're
looking to lose weight and whether
you're a parent by looking at for
frequent locations we can determine
where you live where you work what
restaurants you like to visit the most
whose houses you visit the most by
looking at your credit score we can
assess what level of income you're at
and how much debt you're in by looking
at your contact list we can determine
who your closest friends are how often
you call them and whether or not you've
fallen out with them based on the
frequency of those calls by looking at
your internet history we can determine
any health-related concerns you have
your religious affiliations what your
interests are whether you're planning to
go abroad or not what you're thinking
about purchasing all of these
predictions allow us to create a profile
for each individual on
two sets profile they can detail exactly
who you are as a person how you think
and how likely you are to behave that is
our product a well wrapped package
filled with an individual's behavioral
patterns once we've packaged all this
data into profiles audiences list it's
time to start selling but who do you
sell this information to you're probably
wondering and the answer is damn near
close to whoever wants it right now your
main customers are going to be marketing
companies if we had a list of people who
are health conscious which is something
you can determine by a person's buying
decision then there are a handful of
companies that will want to get their
hands on that list
Jim's personal trainers health based
restaurants food subscription boxes
which are based around healthy eating
online programs for fitness etc etc
those people would love to find out
who's interested in getting fit because
the more targeted and advertisers
campaign is the more return they can see
on their advertising spend and that's
where you come in and sell them those
lists of people that fit the bill but is
that really where it stops of course you
know do you know what else though if
profiles can determine about you they
can determine the riskiness of your
lifestyle and that is something
insurance companies would love to get
their hands on recently purchased a
motorcycle then get ready for that
information to be flagged up by a health
insurance company and for you to begin
paying higher premiums for that health
insurance banks would also love to get
their hands on your information from
your search history they can see whether
you have a history of credit card
purchases or luxury items and from there
they can determine whether to give you
higher or lower interest rates on any
loans that you take out what about
people search websites websites there's
store personal information about people
with which for a fee you can access that
information they'd love to gather data
on a person's name address family
members and whatnot and what about
governments governments would love to
know your exact location especially if
you're a person of interest to them or
what about other data brokers yeah data
brokers sell to other data brokers it's
not as clear cut as scraping data and
selling it off to other
this entire industry is a web of data
brokers selling to other data brokers
who sell to companies that sell to other
data brokers with prices marked up based
on the information that these data
brokers are selling right now that
average email is calculated to be worth
about $89 to a brand over time one can
only imagine how much money information
like a person's political affiliations
are buying decisions or their health
conditions are worth to other data
brokers and companies but it's hard to
fix a price on it
this industry is built in the shadows
with word-of-mouth deals and private
marketplaces being the only spots that
you can buy this information your
information 200 billion dollar industry
that is built up from using your
information and yet with all that being
said there's probably one huge question
that you have right now a question that
you have probably been asking since the
start of this video
chances are if you were born into a
world of surveillance technology in the
Internet hearing about how your data is
passed on like this probably isn't going
to bother you as much as you may want it
to and you're not alone in your apathy
there's a very common sentiment which is
I have nothing to hide therefore nothing
to fear you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs if you aren't doing
anything wrong you have nothing to worry
about and so the industry of data
brokering poses a genuine moral dilemma
if your information is being sold that
you can use various websites absolute
services for free does it really matter
after all data can be used to track down
criminals we have an algorithm that
we're using that will identify a sort of
risk factor for each area it can be used
to predict epidemics and treat diseases
and improve treatments it can be used
for businesses to improve their service
or the quality of the products that they
present to you but what if that date
have got into the wrong hands what if a
data broker or a company sold your
information to an individual without
knowing their real intentions what if an
authoritative government took that
information and use it against citizens
that were openly against them
would you care then or would it be too
late right now less than half of the
data broker companies in the US let you
see what information they have on you
they're a literary services where you
have to pay in order to stop other
companies from using and selling your
information your data isn't really yours
anymore so is it already too late
[Music]
I started this video off trying to
expose this industry and after all my
research I only left feeling more
confused because at the end of the day
so many of the services and apps and
websites that we use that are free rely
on the collection or selling of your
data in order to stay profitable so
would you want to pay a subscription fee
for Instagram or Twitter or Google Maps
if it meant that none of these companies
were collecting your data and for some
of you that hustle would be worth it but
for me personally I'm still on the fence
and I don't know one thing I can say
though is ten needs to be more
regulation things like the GDP are were
a step in the right direction but even
regulations like these have loopholes
and sometimes exists for the sole
purpose of extracting money from a
company bother than protecting your data
and privacy as a whole the data industry
is really interesting and worth
researching if you want to know how your
data is being collected and used and as
with everything I think the more
educated you can become on the subject
the more closer you can become to
finding the right solution for it
thank you so much for watching this
video was all about data and privacy
which is why it's sponsored by North Vee
PN just kidding
I don't think this channel is big enough
for that yet which I'll now note if
you're watching this right now you made
it to the end which is awesome so let me
know in the comments down below I will
respond if you enjoyed the video please
do be sure to smash the like button and
if you didn't like it hit the dislike
button and let me know down below in the
comments and if you like these sorts of
documentary style videos on business
finance and life in general be sure to
hit the subscribe button turn all your
notifications on check out some of my
other videos too it takes me a really
long time to edit these things so your
support is genuinely really appreciated
but all that being said I hope you have
a wonderful rest of the day salut
[Music]
you
[Music]